if everyone has these tendencies which
they certainly do i've noticed that if i
have a guest on my podcast and i think
my audience is fairly open-minded but
then i'll have a guest on that and
they'll hate them
and they'll be like well you can't just
even if you don't agree with them maybe
and maybe they are wrong but like you
can't just cancel people because they
don't agree with you because you're
doing exactly the same thing that the
people you're complaining about well you
know and also maybe you're maybe your
stupid opinions aren't right they're
probably not right and like are you so
sure your life is going so much the way
you want it to go and you're such a
bloody paragon of virtue and the light
is shining out every orifice that
everything you think and say is correct
and everyone who disabuses you of your
notions is evil you're really so sure of
that are you
so you know you wander around and you
think god maybe i should listen to this
person because i'm such an ignorant
bastard and i'm so full of malevolence
and maybe they'll drop one thing on me
that won't make me like miserable and
doomed to hell and to drag everyone else
there too
that's
yeah well
you know i i
i felt something similar when i
finally leaned into listening to you
properly because what was interesting
even after that moment in 2018 watching
that three-minute clip deciding this man
is evil i want nothing to do with him
ever again and of course i didn't think
i would ever have anything to do
[Laughter]
um
people
in my especially people that were
not really connected to the digital
world a lot of my a lot of older men in
my life for example and women in my life
would always tell me
to read your book it's
honestly i people would always say to me
africa you will really love this book i
would have friends of mine send me
lectures i think you're really going to
like this and i would just completely
ignore it and in my mind i'd be thinking
what am i what am i going to find what
am i supposed to like because again i
have this idea of you built up in my
head so i'm finding it very confusing
that people that know me very well are
telling me that there's something that
i'm going to like
right yeah they are confusing but again
for years what the hell
years i ignored it so when i started
watching your lectures late 2019 and
last summer as well
in the beginning i could notice myself
listening to you
and finding
waiting
for a moment where i could say aha see
see right i i knew i was right
and you know what i waited i wait that
moment never came
that moment never came and comes for me
right all the time
and
that again so it's like there wasn't one
moment of being awake and then it's done
so many little tiny seemingly
insignificant moments where i'm just
sitting here by my sofa
just watching and listening observing
myself waiting you know for that
confirmation that i'm right and then it
never coming and then i have to deal
with that and then so
again my curiosity i finally allowed
myself to be curious again and now
jordan i can say you have been one of
the most influential people to me for so
many reasons reasons i couldn't even
mention right now um
but to be able to have the conversations
that i do now publicly
you have
and i i could have never
never imagined this ever in my entire
life this is
things like this don't just happen and i
can't tell you this
oh no
thank you
just
thank you
thank you you got him
it's a pleasure
it's a rough pleasure but
you know did you knew what happened to
me with uh
marvel comics
yeah
that was something
it's really something to see yourself
portrayed you know i got accused of
being a nazi pretty much when all this
happened was really something because i
had been
teaching students
what we're talking about today about
these temptations that you faced and how
people as individuals get sucked into
that totalitarian hell
you know and then
so that was something for that to happen
such a reversal and then to have that
comic book come out well it was surreal
it was absolutely surreal to be
portrayed
because nazi wasn't enough right we had
to go right for the archetype itself
so i think we've raised about 400 000
for charity now
on the basis of that so that was a fun
reversal
but it was really shocking when i first
saw that i i just couldn't believe it i
was very ill at the time too and i
thought this can't be real this has to
be photoshopped this cannot possibly be
happening it's so completely beyond
comprehension
and you know to come from the pen of one
of the foremost black intellectuals and
i i use the racial category only because
that's the categories that he's using to
operate with it
yeah
so
so life is really weird this is true
right
this is true
as this whole conversation illustrates
so
so what have been the personal
consequences for you of writing this
letter and and having it go
i mean yeah yeah i mean have you have
have you been pilloried has
what's happened to you
um
i haven't i haven't i haven't received
and this this is something that
i
don't think about so much actually
because i i prefer to just allow it to
be whatever it is right now to not
expect it or to it just is but i
actually have not received
any pushback
from this
and for it to have been read by over
four million people
and for me to not have been
aggressively dragged through the streets
of social media
you know by my neck it's
why not why hasn't it happened
why do you think what what's what's
operating to protect you do you think
you know what i
it would be very naive of me to think
that my identity markers the ones we've
been speaking about don't have anything
to do with that i think people are more
willing to listen to
what i'm saying because of the fact that
i'm black
if i had been white for example a lot of
what i'm saying the more universal
things that are not specific to me being
black or zimbabwean um
they would have just been dismissed
because there are many things people
have been saying over the past years
that are just common sense they make
sense people have genuine questions
but no one will listen to it because the
first thing they will see is that you
inhabit a white body so you don't get to
speak
you know
so i think people are more willing
um
to hear what i have to say because of
that and i think it's also because
i'm not preaching to anyone i'm not
telling anyone what to do yeah that's a
yeah
right i'm not an
academic i'm not trying to give you data
and
this is not about that this is a very
personal account from someone that has
been in it i'm not righteous i'm not
above you or below you
right this is just me
saying hey no i'm opting out of this
game and we all get to opt out
you know and i i think that's why it has
been received
very well because i'm speaking from the
eye i'm speaking from my own personal
experience and i think it can be very
hard to
dispute that well you can't well you see
there's something interesting about that
too a because one of the mantras of of
the left i hate to use these categories
but we're we're stuck with it at the
moment yes yes
you know
the the uh implicit truth of
subjectivity
and the thing is they're scared yes
right and the thing is there's something
right about that
because
you are
there is a domain of knowledge
that you have privileged access to that
no one can dispute
and that domain of knowledge is
your honest representation of your
subjective experience
and that it does have the kind of power
that you just described
and so there is there's some sense in
noting that as a form of truth
but then it
the claim seems to have got twisted and
perverted in some way which which is it
kind of gets elevated narcissistically
it's like because i have this domain
where i'm
i am the only person who has access to
those experiences
then all of a sudden that gets in it
gets inflated in this political way into
a narcissistic claim that you know
that means overall my truths are as good
as any truth and they're as good as
anyone else's and there's an error there
right because there's despite the fact
that there are things that you can say
that only you can say that no one can
dispute
there are all sorts of things that you
can't say that you don't know and that
are absolutely subject to dispute yes
and so it's it's it's the it's the
narcissistic inflation of the claim
beyond its reasonable boundaries and
then
your conscience i think was operating in
you to say
well where are the boundaries of this
claim like the
let's take the war so to speak between
black people and the and police in the
united states well obviously that's a
problem but it's a really really complex
problem
and maybe we want to have an instant
solution to it but we don't have an
instant solution to it and so
the claim is well this is a problem and
then the next claim is well it's based
in racism and then the next claim is
it's based in white supremacy it's like
well
wait a second
there's a problem here
and the problem with
coming up with the solution so rapidly
is
well you don't know
you actually don't know this is actually
a really complicated problem and your
intuition that it's a problem is is dead
on and your intuition that
it would be reasonably more reasonable
morally to be concerned about that is
dead on but the right approach is
questioning not
answering
and i think part of the reason that i've
got away with my lectures online i think
maybe and as a professor for that matter
is
i do my best to always question
and even my public lectures that on the
tour
i usually think of a question that i'm
trying to answer and then when i go out
and lecture i'm i'm trying to explore
the question i'm not telling the
audience what they should think i don't
know what they should think i don't even
know what i should think
and so i can guide them through the
process of exploration and
and that that seems to
well so far that seems to be working and
that's what we're doing in this
conversation and that's partly what
makes it a good conversation you know is
we're trying to figure something out
that we don't know